[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hi there.
This is Magnus Hyttsten
for The Developer Show.
We're at the
TensorFlow Dev Summit.
And next to me, I have Raz.
You talked about something
new in TensorFlow, the TFMA,
TensorFlow Model Analysis.
Can you tell me what that is?
RAZ MATHIAS: Well, it's a
new component that we just
launched yesterday.
We've been using it
internally for a while.
It allows us to
basically measure
the performance of our
models in a sliced fashion.
And it runs over a
distributed infrastructure.
So it's not just a
sample kind of thing.
And it lets us take
a large population
and zoom in, dimension
by dimension,
and really understand what the
failure modes of our models
are.
I think that that's something
that we're starting to do.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So that
sounds like a lot of boxes,
a lot of training episodes.
Is that something I can use?
RAZ MATHIAS: Absolutely.
I'm glad you asked
that question.
So if you go to the
GitHub, all you have to do
is Git clone, the TensorFlow
slash model dash analysis
repository.
There's an example there
that I talked about today,
where you can run end
to end from a data set
through TensorFlow
transform, through training,
through serving,
evaluation, all locally.
So you can play
with these things.
You can experiment with them.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And
this is part of the TFX,
the TensorFlow extended
Framework, correct?
RAZ MATHIAS: It is indeed.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So the
question is, how do developers
get involved in this?
RAZ MATHIAS: Well,
you go to GitHub.
You go to the TensorFlow
repository slash model dash
analysis.
You Git clone the
whole thing locally.
You run the scripts.
You follow the code lab.
You modify things.
You have fun.
You give us feedback.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Excellent.
So go out there, do some serious
model analysis with TFMA.
I'm Magnus Hyttsten
for The Developer Show.
We're at the TensorFlow
Dev Summit here with Raz.
[MUSIC PLAYING]